hey everybody welcome back to park
attacks in the last episode we finished
archipelago adventures and today it's
time for another adventure in Adventure
Island now I want to talk about the
scenario a little bit more than the
scenarios so far mainly because of the
overall critical response I guess you
could call it to this scenario so this
is one of the scenarios that I made and
I've seen that for a lot of people this
is sort of a brick wall in difficulty
this one is quite a bit more difficult
to complete than a lot of the scenarios
that came before it
so if we look at the description for
instance before we go into the design of
the scenario itself it says that this is
a small island park with a unique
observation tower that wants to attract
more guests but the cold and wet climate
is keeping visitors away so that's one
thing the climates if the scenario is
not very conducive to finishing the
scenario so it's gonna be cold and wet
and you can see it's minus 2 degrees
already so this ride is over here as a
bit of a hint that it's probably best to
try and build indoors whenever you can
to get that rain protection so that's
one thing to keep in mind and also we
need to get a Happiness rating of at
least 80% and I don't recall exactly if
we've had that on earlier scenarios but
it's it's quite a difficult rating to
get I haven't tried this and I haven't
completed the scenario myself but it
seems so far from my playthroughs if the
other scenario is that getting ratings
of above 80% is pretty difficult so
that's also gonna be a bit of a
challenge but I think by far the biggest
problem with the scenario and the thing
that makes it very difficult is the fact
that you start off with a pre-built park
which has a number of issues and in
hindsight also I'm not sure how happy I
am with the scenario in hindsight I
would have probably made the park much
more functional because this is one of
the earlier parks in the scenario mode
even though we're getting somewhere near
the halfway point at this point but yeah
there's a number of issues with this
park and if you don't fix them at least
right from the start or as you're
playing the scenario it might become
very difficult later
down the road to get to that amount of
guests or get the guests to be happy
enough so first of all we've got the
coaster killer B over here which I think
it looks neat enough but it's super
inefficient because there are no block
breaks anywhere on this thing except for
the end so it only runs two trains and
you can see that the trains are the
typical Eurofighter for the culture of
coaster trains which aren't very good
for efficiency so that's a problem it's
also only 450 for a ticket which is not
nearly enough I think you can ask around
15 dollars for this at least that seems
to be a good amount so far for any
thrilling coaster you might be able to
ask more money but I'll leave it for 15
for now Sam actually goes for the
twister
whenever you get rides at the start of a
scenario actually I would highly suggest
looking in the prices and see if there's
anything that you can raise in there
because there often will be and that's
usually a good way to make things
profitable so with a $15 price this ride
it should be decently profitable but
it's never gonna make you that much
money because it's just that inefficient
so that's one thing now there's also the
observation tower over here which is an
elevator in it so you can ask money for
the elevator and earn money on the
observation tower but to be honest what
I think is probably the better decision
here is to put a sign somewhere over
here blocking people from entering this
whole area because really this is a huge
part of the challenge of the scenario
the map is quite large and well that's
not a problem per se you can also always
just start building somewhere and just
move out from there we've got this huge
path leading almost throughout the whole
map that we've got so there's this
really long stretch of path where
there's no rides and no food or anything
that people can spend money on so this
is making your Park a lot less busy and
less profitable so really one of the
first things that I'm gonna do to try
and make this scenario a bit easier is
put a sign somewhere in here and every
time I build some rides along this
stretch of land
just move up that sign until eventually
we get to the observation tower itself
and then I'll build some stuff around
this but yeah that's something to keep
in mind as well and actually I think
that's just about it
so the existing rides and the way that
the park is laid out is a huge problem
with this map and that's what a lot of
the challenge I think comes from if you
manage to fix these issues by reworking
it a little bit I think the scenario
should become pretty doable I don't want
to say too much here because I still
need to finish this scenario but yeah
this is where a lot of the challenge if
this scenario comes from so in hindsight
I would say to myself you know I should
have made this scenario a bit
differently and made it easier or at
least more clear how to fix this but for
now this is what we're set up with and
I'm gonna try my best to turn this
failing miserable little theme park into
a successful one so let's go all right
then here we go
and I'm gonna start the scenario by
reworking some of the scenery that we
get from the start because this is all
pretty simple and relatively sparsely
themed
so I want to add some more detail and a
few extra buildings to the area that we
start out with and actually bekku now is
making this I wanted to keep a lot of
the scenery and many of the scenarios a
little bit simple so that it would be
easy to emulate the style for players
regardless of whatever skill level you
have or whether you're interested to
play the scenarios from a scenery
perspective like I'm doing or whether
you're more interested in just a
gameplay aspect of it so for that reason
a lot of the scenery is actually quite
simple but in my case I do want to focus
on the scenery so I think it'll be just
nice to add a little bit more detail
into some of the things that's been
built so far reworked some of the
buildings and also at this food court in
here because once I closed off the part
of the park with the observation tower
that's also where the existing food
court is so I'm gonna need something
near the entrance area just so people
can get their food and there
which in this case are I think just the
coffee and pretzels which is not the
best choice but I mean it gives the
guests the sustenance that they need so
I'm honestly just gonna stick with that
for now I also have a few other things
that actually want to address about this
scenario and the coaster as well that I
forgot to mention in the intro while I'm
just building this small toilet building
over here as another part of some extra
scenery so the coaster even though it's
a Eurofighter like some of the coaches
that I've been building in the scenario
playthrough so far is a lot more
inefficient than any of the coasters
that I've built in Nova labs or in
mystic aces partly because the layout is
just much longer I didn't feel the need
for extra additional block breaks in the
middle of the layouts on the euro
fighters that I made in some earlier
episodes because their layouts are
pretty short but this layout takes a
long time to complete so that makes it
take even longer for the cars to you
know wait for another car to complete
the circuit before they can climb the
lift Hill so that's one thing and also
the station is terribly inefficient
design with one station with an exit and
an entrance on both sides and what I did
with all of my Eurofighter so far is to
have an exit station and an entrance
station so while one car is unloading
another car is loading passengers so
that makes it a little bit more
efficient as well and I suppose that
goes into the small tip also for any
other players if you have these coasters
with very small trains or coasters that
you want to quickly load and unload new
cars on having an exit station and an
entrance station separately can really
help to make the operations a bit
smoother I see how that's basically
about the coaster but yeah but the
difficulty in this park some of the some
of it I think is quite well justified
like the weather for instance being
quite difficult to manage the goals
being quite difficult and also really
the park that you start out with with
these rides that are under priced and
inefficient I think that's fine as well
but the whole thing about the path
leading up to this observation tower is
kind of a problem that I always I was
always super annoyed with with roller
coaster tycoon scenarios whenever they
did this kind of thing for me
carts and coasters sticks out the most
as a park where I always have to sort of
redesign the park right at the start of
the scenario to try and make it work and
to be honest I always dislike it when
you have to do this so in hindsight
that's my biggest perk with this
scenario as well and one gripe then in
hindsight I should say yeah that's
honestly sort of an artificial
difficulty of the scenario and that sort
of takes the fun out of it so I guess to
review my own kind of thing and try and
be critical on myself there that said it
is also something that once you do know
how to get around it it shouldn't be too
much of an issue anymore so I hope I'm
not gonna fail on this scenario we'll
see I don't want to say anything too
soon but I think it should be alright so
for this part of the video I decided to
build a lot of flat rides instead of a
rollercoaster just because I don't
really have a good choice of a
rollercoaster to build there's already
the Eurofighter there so that's not
something that I can try and the other
options are a powered coaster or a
junior coaster and even though I once
got one of these in the park just for
aesthetic reasons it's not gonna give a
lot of profits or allow people to spend
more time and spend more money in the
park so I'm focusing on getting some of
the thrilling flat rides in first so
hence why I'm building the drop tower
over there as well as the the crazy I
forgot the name crazy spinning super
thrilling nauseating flat ride and also
this wave swinger so I think that should
be a better start to this scenario than
building a coaster because you do get
some more value for your money with this
it's also a good way to give a bit of a
layout to the park I decided to have a
pretty heavy use of paths without having
any crazy patterns or anything like that
like I did in some of the earlier
because I'm trying to keep this quite
simple and like it's a bit of a rustic
local kind of Park inspired a bit by I
would say American parks like Dollywood
or Silver Dollar City and honestly also
the broke coasters planet coaster park
which has these really cool part
elements at different elevations as well
there's always a lot of fun you can have
with paths on different elevations and
kind of diving underneath each other and
things like that so I decided to put a
bit of that into the park as well
instead of going crazy with the path
textures it's mostly just going to be
tarmac and wood for this park so yeah
that's basically the start of the
scenario and I'm already earning some
money with it so that's pretty good it
looks like it's been functional so far
so let's go into a little bit of a short
real-time overview and see how the park
is doing before I continue so I was
wondering how the park would be doing at
this early stage in the game and to be
completely honest it's doing a lot
better than I expected my happiness
rating is actually 100% so that turned
out to be nowhere near as hard to get as
I remember I think before I was mostly
looking at the ratings left by your
guests which are a lot harder to get and
I'm not sure if this is how it works and
it's a little bit embarrassing that I
don't know but as far as I remember the
ratings that are left by your guests are
this kind of exit poll as they exit the
park but then the ratings based on
current factors are you know whatever
the guests are thinking right now at the
moment so if you look at this basically
the current factors is like an average
of all of these ratings of the guests in
the park so the ratings based on current
factors are a lot more live data ish and
the ratings left by guests they only
start improving once the guests start
leaving the park and they get that kind
of exit poll so that's a pretty big
division between how these stats work
because that means that getting the
happiness to go up and all of those
other factors is going to be a lot
easier than
the experiences and prices ratings so
that's something to keep in mind and
something that I wasn't thinking of
before I went into the scenario and also
I'm on about 260 guests in the park
which is a pretty good actually for this
early in the game I didn't bill too much
yet but I think that despite being not
very efficient and this is a pretty
important point I think Killer Bee is
really good at attracting people to the
park and making them happy because it's
quite a good thrill ride and even if
it's really inefficient it's got an
extreme excitement rating so it's still
pretty good regardless of that so really
I've seen some people play the scenario
by deleting this coaster and using some
of the money that you get from it
because you don't get all of the
construction costs to build a better
coaster but I'm actually not sure if
that's the best way to approach this
because having this in here it is pretty
much a free coaster and a small head
start to get you going so even if it
doesn't earn that much money it's still
something for the guests to come to your
park for and to spend some time in so
I'm gonna keep that around and I think
that's probably a good idea and just
keep building from here so my plan is
basically to build a small family
coaster over here I think they're all
neatly round up this part of the park
then we should be somewhere between 300
and 400 guests and we'll hopefully have
a little bit more money and some
researched new coasters or something
like that to build a cool area over here
as well and hopefully that'll be enough
to reach the goal of 500 guests so
without further ado let's get back into
building stuff so once again I'm
building a family coaster but this time
I want to do it a little bit differently
than everything so far so most of the
times that have built one of these
things so far it's been just more of a
kiddie coaster just the very short and
slow layout with a few helixes before
you get back into this station so this
time I want to do a little bit more than
that and make it more of a family ride
so something that can thrill the younger
guests but still be approachable enough
for older
or their moms or dads or whatever to
ride as well and I was mostly inspired
by for Bolton which is a zero family
coaster in Busch Gardens which is
absolutely one of the best family
coasters in the world probably it does a
lot it has a dark ride section it has a
launch just lots of elements actually
some elements that I don't want to spoil
because if you're ever gonna write that
thing I think it's better to not know
anything about it and not be like me
where you just try to find out
everything about every coaster ever but
yeah it was mostly inspired by that
coaster which looks kind of similar to
this one in game I figured only
difference is that it also has a
triangular track but I think this
coaster type works well enough for what
I'm trying to go for here so for one
I've made the lift hill a little bit
taller then I've usually made these
things but not that much because I want
to make use of the terrain here so one
of the really cool things that for
Bolton does is halfway through the
layout it's it reaches this point where
it goes down into a valley and it has
this mid-course brake run with a roof
over it and if I remember correctly this
is actually where a narrow suspended
coaster used to be before which had a
very similar drop so it's kind of paying
homage to that former ride but at the
same time I think it looks really cool
so I wanted to build something like that
on the Riverside or no actually this is
a pretty big body of water isn't it on
the on the water side here so that's
something I'll get back to later because
I do want to theme that quite a bit and
then after that the layout just kind of
goes back and forth on this pretty
lengthy section filled with airtime
Hills and helixes so nothing too intense
but it's definitely a little bit more
intense than the average kiddie coaster
that I've been building so far and
especially after the break run here it
hits a pretty intense point is quite a
kind of high top speed in there and I
bet this is a decently thrilling coaster
but still I think it's at least doable
for most families so I was inspired by
per Bolton also to put this little roof
for the mid-course brake run not
necessarily because there would be any
kind of pre-show or anything like that
in here
but it just looks nice so I like to also
emulate that I guess also in the weather
of this park it would be pretty handy to
have this little roof over the break one
here because if I remember anything
being absolutely terrible on a roller
coaster is if you're stuck on a brake
run while it's raining and there's no
cover over the brake run that is
absolutely horrid that said if all goes
well the trains should never have to
stop on this brake run but it's a good
moment to kind of catch your breath
before you plunge down into what's a
pretty intimidating drop if this is one
of your first coasters of this size for
instance so we've got that little house
in there I also wanted to actually build
it slightly different than I usually do
so the walls of the building aren't
actually walls as you might have noticed
they are the shape pieces just to make
sure that I can built the walls on half
a tile size so that the roof can have
this overhang which is something that I
usually don't do because it's quite
difficult to pull that off but since
this is a pretty simple building I think
it works quite well and it does a good
job I think of selling the idea that
this is some kind of over hanging wall
and it makes the building feel like it's
a little bit less restricted by the grid
now one of my favorite parts of this
ride actually probably my favorite part
of this ride turned out to be the
station I didn't really expect too much
of it usually I just go into these
things without any plan and just kind of
come up with what it's gonna look like
while I'm building it but this station
actually turned out to be pretty nice so
halfway through this build I decided to
actually put some extra effort into it
so we've got the basic generic
rectangular shape of the station here
but to avoid that very boring
rectangular feel I wanted to have a
small overhang toward the exit over
there so toward the front in the that
whole area with the each air swing and
then also aspire because
spires just make everything look so much
nicer and a bit of a more interesting
roof shape as well so it goes a little
bit steeper in the middle of it and I
have to give credits here for the
inspiration for this building to
estimate wrong on the park context
discord server I believe it was s true
tone not entirely sure but yeah I'm
pretty sure who built this really
amazing Alpine building and this
building basically served as the
inspiration for the station building
right here he very similarly had this
kind of general layout of the building
with the spire and I thought that would
be something really nice to follow and
something that fits into the theme of
this scenario which even though it's
quite generic I think the theme kind of
comes through in the use of material and
colors so everything is quite brown and
d saturated and using a lot of wooden
materials and colors so with that whole
kind of basic idea of the theme I think
there's still a lot that you can do with
the generic theme of this park so yeah
that's basically the station it also has
this little interesting roof over the
final brake run which is partly because
I think it looks quite nice without that
I feel like this station would look
awfully rectangular and boxy but also
it's just another one of these things
where if if there is a train stuck in
the station and you're arriving as the
second train you'll be stopped on that
block break sections so it's it's a
little bit nicer to actually have a roof
over there as well
so there's that and also I decided to
put a roof over the final part of the
queue because this is where you'll most
likely have to wait and this is a very
rainy scenario after all so I don't
actually know if that you know makes the
experiences for the guests any happier
if that increases their happiness rating
if they're able to find cover throughout
the park but at the very least it can't
be a bad thing so that's what something
I wanted to add in there and then
there's finally a lot of foliage around
this right just because
to make it seem like it's really horsing
through a forest so that's basically it
for this part of the video I just want
to take some time to look at the ride
and then we'll continue so here's our
thus far unnamed little terrain coaster
and this actually made me realize just
how much I like building terrain
coasters it's really cool to be able to
make use of the elevation to use up all
of the energy that you build up with the
lift hill so as you can see the lift
cell isn't even that long but you could
still manage to get a long layout out of
it and by the final brake run its lost
most of its speed but it doesn't really
slow down too much throughout the layout
it more or less keeps the same kind of
speed so that's what I really like about
terrain coasters definitely allows for a
lot more creativity there actually I
maybe wanted to follow this for a little
bit but I can always save that for the
end as well that said I've got a lot of
comments about showing the ratings of
coasters and I'm sorry that I forgot to
show this so far I actually wanted to do
that in the last episode as well but I'm
gonna have to make a little bit of a
habit of that but it seems like the
ratings for this aren't so good
obviously the intensity rating is still
pretty low because there is nothing
really intense happening here but that
said for the guests who are okay with
that I can still ask a decent amount of
money for this actually because the
excitement rating is actually still
quite high and then decoration is
amazing but I've also noticed that the
amazing decoration or at least the high
decoration is quite a standard for most
of my coasters so far so it shouldn't be
too difficult to get that but then again
I think this station and this building
over here are what really contribute to
that high rating see ya
overall I'm actually really happy with
this coaster and it also fits the space
that I had available quite well and
there's even some nice moments of path
interactions over here you can actually
have a pretty cool view of the coaster
and the queue also has some nice
interaction with the final part of the
layout as well say overall this is
actually one of my favorite layouts of
the blade through so far
now as for the park itself we're making
a good amount of money actually even
more than I used to so that's really
good and also I've gotten some good
rides for the well whatever I'm gonna
expand in over here I can even put this
thing indoors which is gonna be handy
for the rain and finally the coasters
aren't too great yet but from the
research that I've seen so far I'm gonna
get this stand-up coaster next and I
really want to build that because I
haven't built it so far in the
playthrough so yeah I think that's gonna
be interesting so that further ado let's
get back to building some stuff alright
now before I get into the standup
coaster and I'm sorry for teasing you a
little bit I didn't realize when I was
recording the last clip that I would
spend more time doing other stuff first
I I want to add a staff room and a
training room because I didn't do that
so far and not having these in your Park
is can become pretty problematic over
time as well so I thought it would be
good to add these while we were at it
and also a few covers underneath the
coaster tracks and this is something
that I don't always point out but in
real life if a coaster is very close to
a path or going just right over it
there's usually coaster nets or some
kind of roof to prevent loose articles
from people riding the coaster from you
know hitting people's heads or any other
body parts on the pants downs down the
down the track so that's just a bit of a
safety thing that I like to put in the
game as well just to make things feel a
little bit more realistic and after that
I moved on to a few flat rights that I
wanted to build before I got into the
standup coaster and the first one is
this Riptide over here and yeah the
reason that I built this thing is
actually that I thought it would be
great to put this under a roof for
another indoor flat ride but in
hindsight that was actually a terrible
idea because these things turn out to be
pretty tall when they start doing their
spinning thing
and I didn't really account for that so
this building ended up being much taller
than I expected beforehand and it looks
a little bit clumsy so I spent quite a
good deal of time trying to figure out
how to make this building look a little
bit nicer and incorporate it a little
bit better in the surrounding areas what
I ended up going for is just this very
generic shed style structure I suppose
but covering the exit and the entrance
in such a way then it sort of helps the
building get some you know lower parts
to not make it just this straight box
that's really big in the middle of the
park but also have some extra decoration
and things on the side of it to make it
blend in a little bit nicer with the
rest of the park I think in the end it
works alright but it's definitely not
the best ride to put indoors you can
also see that every now and then I
messed up and it was sticking through
the walls or the roofs of the building
and it I had to adjust some things but
in the end it should be safe and it
works in terms of the rain protection
that's quite good I also have to say
that I didn't really have much better
rights at my disposal a lot of the rides
in this park are actually quite large so
it's hard to put them under a roof maybe
it's because I got unlucky with the
research or it's just because I don't
want to put too much effort into
building roofs overrides but that was
definitely part of this struggle as well
now the next right that I put into the
park is this G lock and I don't know if
this is the first year lock that I'm
building in the campaign mode but it's
definitely one of the first it's one of
those slightly more rare rides but it's
quite good in game and has some decent
stats and I should also say in real life
this is one of my favourite flat rides I
wrote it first in Tivoli Gardens
in Copenhagen last year and I didn't
expect this to be a ride that I liked
because I don't handle brides that do
multiple directions of rotation very
well I kind of get quite nauseous
quickly
but this thing didn't end up making me
as nauseous as I expected and the forces
that you get on this are actually really
cool so this this is slightly different
I think
the one in Tivoli since that one is only
two seats per arm but the overall idea
of the ride is very similar so these
things actually get a thumbs up for me
and I like to put them in parks whenever
I can because they're a nice fight to
look at they're fun to see their their
whole rotation thing go around has so
many ridiculous moving parts and it's
just a fun ride in general now moving on
we finally get the stand up coaster here
and this is actually quite an
interesting experience for me at the
time this is actually my first taco
stand up coaster that I'm building in
the game because this is one of the most
recent additions to the coaster roster
it might have actually been the most
recent addition and since it's been
added I've only played campaign mode and
you don't get this coaster very often in
campaign at least I haven't gotten it
very often so far so yeah I just haven't
gotten around to building one of these
but I actually like these and that's a
bit of a halt sake
actually so for those of you who aren't
as much of a coaster nerd as I am this
is a Togo stand up coaster and people
usually call it that because the company
that makes them which is a Japanese
company is called Togo and it's
notorious for being absolutely terrible
at making roller coasters a lot of their
coasters are very uncomfortable a little
bit old and quite simple they don't do a
lot of interesting things and when they
tried to do that it usually failed
pretty miserably so they don't have a
really good reputation but I do think
they are underrated and maybe even hated
more than they deserve because when you
look back at it they were actually the
company that invented this stand-up
coaster and built the first stand-up
coaster and back in the days they were
actually quite thrill blazing it's just
that a lot of the rides have aged quite
poorly and also otoko builds a lot of
coasters in America that were usually
quite bad and I don't know what this was
related to exactly I've heard some
stories about it being simply that the
manufacturers
in America because I don't think they
transported the track pieces to America
but rather they had a plant in America
where they built their stuff that the
manufacturer locally wasn't quite as
good and also America just got unlucky I
think a lot of the good toe goes that do
exist are mostly in Japan and for my
money I've been able to ride to ride two
of them among which actually the first
stand-up coaster it wasn't originally
built as a stand up coaster but it got
these stand up coaster trains to ride in
Yomiuri land and I expected it to be
very painful but it was actually quite
smooth and a really fun ride experience
given that the restraints weren't too
comfortable the ride itself was actually
not too rough and quite comfortable and
the forces that you get in the loop are
actually really cool because you were
standing on your feets so you really
feel all of the g-forces like pull all
of your blood down to your feet and it's
really cool especially because their
loops are a little bit circular so
really heavy g-forces in there so yeah
all together I like this ride I like
this coaster type there were probably
some really bad ones out there but my
experience with it so far is quite good
and I like it in game as well and has a
really cool track design and it's just
one of those rights that you don't build
too often it's a bit a little bit of a
gimmick ride but yeah I like it so it
gets a thumbs up for me and incidentally
I should also say that the other toka
coaster that I've been on is bandits in
Yomiuri land which at the time when it
was built I believe was the fastest
coaster in the world and the height
difference between its lowest and
highest point actually somewhere around
70 meters it's actually insane and
really even though it's not officially a
hyper coaster it's sort of is the first
hyper coaster and apparently it was the
inspiration for the first actual hyper
coaster in being built so really also
quite a good coaster and I think it's
even held up quite well over the years
it's not super smooth but it's decently
smooth definitely not painful and it has
some really good moments in any case god
I said it again I can't stop myself
there I'm sore
guys I reached the scenario girls
they're in the middle of my time-lapse
because I wasn't paying attention so
we're gonna miss out on the confetti
later on but I decided to fill in the
remaining space that I had left with a
suspended coaster
just because I felt partly that this was
a good way to round up the types of
courses that we have you know you have
two very thrilling intense coasters with
the the Eurofighter and the stand-up
coaster and then two more family
coasters with the suspended and the
family the family coaster I guess that
works so it's also quite nice because
these coasters I think are best when
they're able to use their terrain to an
advantage so I tried as much as I could
to build this up to the hill and
maintain a very similar speed throughout
the ride by having the first sections of
the right be more up hill and having the
lower sections I kind of cross the water
like that at some point I also thought
that this would be a good idea and
extending it over to the other side of
the path but that really didn't work too
well I think it's more it's more
realistic to keep it just on this side
of the hill and finish it here so both
of these coasters also have pretty
simple color schemes I wanted to go for
these color schemes because I think they
work quite well together when you see
the park from a distance and it was a
little bit inspired also by a Japanese
theme parks which very often just have
these really simple colour schemes and
really simple looks to their coasters
and I don't know what made me think of a
Japanese park when I was looking at this
map but it's partly just that Togo
coaster being over there and having such
a typical Japanese coaster layouts very
simple the kind of low low tech actually
not to be too insulting there but
there's there's just a certain look to
Japanese parks that would actually be
really cool to try and recreate at some
point in time maybe I'll do that on one
of the Japanese scenarios that are gonna
come up but I should probably not spoil
too much about that
so I've also missed a ride which I've
placed on the waterfront there that's
just a small plane carousel get another
ride in for the kiddies also a good ride
to put a roof over so that's something
that I'll do later on and in the
meantime I decided to work a little bit
on the foliage on the side of the
suspended coaster one of the things that
these courses also do really well is
explore these natural areas that they're
built into I really love it when these
suspended coasters just kind of swing
their way through a forest and up and
down various hills it's just a coaster
that's so good exploring the the natural
terrain that's around it and I found
some inspiration I guess here from a
roller coaster called
Eagle Eagle fortress in Korea which is
generally known as one of the best
rollercoasters to have ever been built
and yet it's been out of I think yeah it
hasn't been removed I'm not sure if it's
been removed but it's it's been standing
but not operating for a really long time
and the thing is that only a few roller
coaster enthusiasts from the US have
been on this thing but almost everybody
who has been on it has been raving about
it you could see a POV on YouTube you
could see that it swings way more than
any coaster should it definitely looks
like it wasn't designed to swing as much
as it does but because of that it's a
really intense and unique ride or it was
at least and probably just the perfect
example of suspended coaster and what it
can do it's really amazing at going up
and down these hills and just crashing
through these forests while swinging in
some crazy directions just a really cool
coaster that's both intense but also
super scenic see I pure if you're into
watching POVs on YouTube of random
coasters I highly recommend checking out
Eagles fortress it's really interesting
to watch how especially toward the end
of the ride it goes absolutely haywire
and swings in crazy directions
anyway that's just about it for this
park so let's take a quick look and how
it's doing all right so here's the
finished park so I just want to give a
quick overview of what everything looks
like
and also what some of the stats and
things like that are on these coasters
so first off we've got the suspended
coaster over here which is actually not
that great in terms of stats and this is
making me think that this might not be
the greatest ride for a scenario play
but that said I am actually really happy
with how the layouts turned out a lot of
these will kind of go back and forth
like this through the forest on some
kind of hillside I know some of them
have some really cool path interaction
as well or interaction with some kind of
lake in the center of a park I believe
and the one in Cedar Point does that for
instance but this one is probably most
similar to Eagles fortress except a
little bit less intense I also just
found out that it has been removed um
according to the roller coaster database
it's been removed in 2015 so that's very
sad to see but at least you can always
find it on the internet and its archives
in POV videos for now though let's just
follow this thing as it goes around in
the other train that is so this one is
definitely not as intense but I still
think it does some decent swinging it's
really hard to predict it as bends like
this are really good for the swinging as
are just a short straight section in the
middle of some curves so yeah altogether
not too bad even if it isn't that
intense and really just more of a decent
family ride I think these things are
also best when they come really close to
the ground just because that I know that
see that feels very scary for a lot of
these rides the only one that I've been
on is ninja in Six Flags great a Six
Flags Magic Mountain but whenever it
almost touches the ground for me that's
always the the most the most fun parts
of these rides especially when it swings
a lot at the bottom of those drops and
it's closer to ground
touching the trees that's what these
things do really well I think just that
general interaction with the scenery
around them and then over here we've got
the stand up coaster with Oh some really
good earnings actually and some really
good stats as well we've got an extreme
excitement rating so that's super good
actually let's follow this thing is it
goes around this is also one of the most
popular actually this is the most
popular ride in the park
the trains are almost always full which
is really cool to see so over here for
instance this is a very janky transition
but that's just how to go does it so I
think that fits the layout most of all
into a double corkscrew and some more
janky transitions and simple curves some
people call this the the the Japanese
helix of death or the Togo helix of
death many togo's have this have this
crazy helix on it that's just the Togo
thing so I decided to put that on this
layout as well and yeah that's it for
this ride so altogether I actually
really like the way at least these two
coasters look together on this hillside
I decided to keep this open a little bit
more because when everything is forest
you can't really see the forest through
the trees you need to have some planes
everywhere just to be able to tell where
the forest is so on this ride it's more
forest which I think fits the type of
right that it is and this one is more
kind of built on the plains on this hill
so yeah that's this is actually my
favorite part of the park I didn't
expect it to work out as well but the
overall look of the two coasters as well
as this area with all the different flat
rides is actually quite cool now I
haven't talked about the top spin during
the time lapse but I decided to set this
up in a way that you're actually looking
toward the sea and there's not much of a
barrier here actually maybe not the
safest thing but I really like it and of
course there's also sort of an audience
for this ride but that said with it
being turned toward the sea you are
looking to the back of these people kind
of wish that it were a top spin like
silicon in phantasialand
is for instance where you've got seats
facing to different sides which
quite cool although in telecom it's a
bit annoying I think because it means
that you have the odds of possibly
staring at a wall for the majority of
the ride and even though it's a really
nice wall it's not the best thing so
that's those rides we've already checked
this one out and might as well do a
quick POV of Killer Bee I mean it's out
there anyway so this is a killer bee
doing its thing I do like the layout for
this thing again it's not a very
efficient coaster and it being here in
the in the scenario isn't even that much
of a help at the start but still
something fun to just look at and see it
go around so actually something that I
do want to talk a bit about for at least
shortly in this video is a comments that
I got on the last video giving me the
idea to maybe pause the game while I'm
building and then letting the game play
to see the guests come in and see how
the park is running and I have to say I
like the idea especially for the this
video for this this time-lapse and
real-time video concept where you can
sort of focus the time-lapse on just
making things look as nice as possible
and then having the real-time sections
focus more on how the park ends up
working so for the next video I want to
try that at least at the start but I
also have to say I just like to keep the
game unpassed while I'm playing and
maybe this is just because I'm used to
playing the old-school rollercoaster
[ __ ] games when you were not allowed to
pause the game while you were building
things or maybe it's just because I like
to see the park go around while I'm
building stuff and kind of do some
multitasking where I'm building while
also trying to manage the park in real
time I think there's a lot of the fun of
these games kind of revolves from that
for me as well trying to tend to
different things at the same time
god this thing looks so cool it's
definitely a little bit slower than the
real-life counterpart
but still actually maybe that's because
it's at the end of the yeah it's at the
end of the cycle but yeah where was I
actually write the pausing and unpausing
but I do want to try it for the next
video but I have to be honest I'll
probably stick with what I'm doing right
now and the way I'm playing right now
just because for me that's just the most
fun way to do things
anyway let's wrap up this part so sort
of split into two areas one last thing
they actually never talked about is I
tried to make this area look a little
bit more modern so this is some of the
more fancy stuff also the observation
tower some slightly different paths and
more of the buildings whereas the other
part of the park is more just foliage
and some simple asphalt paths so there's
definitely a slightly different vibe
over here but I do think it all fits
together quite nicely but yeah really
that's the basic set up I think it's a
it's been a decent way to fill in this
island even though it's quite large and
with that all said I think it's a good
time to check out what else we've got so
unfortunately I can't show you the
animation of getting the trophy here but
obviously you get the observation tower
which they point right on the top of the
island over here which actually looks
pretty cool
I really like this as a trophy not to
suddenly brag about myself here I just
the way that they implemented it into
the map looks really cool so over here
we have ice shelf Islands but that's not
the only scenario that we've got from
the finishing Adventure Island here we
also got Biscayne Beach and I've heard a
lot of stories about Biscayne Beach this
is another one of those scenarios that a
lot of people seem to struggle with and
actually the same goes for ice shelf
islands because it's very different
theme and I've heard that the terrain is
quite difficult as well as the research
so both of these are gonna be very
interesting I think I'm gonna do ice
shelf islands first and then get back to
Batavia okay because that's been there
for a while and I just want to do ice
shelf islands for now because we've had
quite a few tropical island maps so I
think
nice to switch it up a little bit and go
to pretty much the opposite of that so
next time I'll try and work on a decent
ice shelf Islands so I hope you guys
enjoyed this video and hope to see you
all next time